على قيد الحياه بل وجاهز للعمل واستعمال
دهائه السياسيه كما قال للتلفزيون
يحتفل هذا العجوز بعيد ميلاده المئه ولد
لعائله يهوديه في المانيا عام
وفره من المحرقه النازيه في سن الخامسه
عشره الى الولايات المتحده اصبح مستشارا
للامن القومي ووزير الخارجيه في عهد
الرئيسين ريتشارد نيكسون وجيرالد فورد من
ابرز سياسي مرحله الحرب البارده ومهندسي
العلاقه بين الولايات المتحده والصين
والاتحاد السوفيتي سابقا وما زال ليومنا
هذا يتمسك بنهجه الواقعي الذي يوازن بين
المصالح والمخاطر خصوصا في التعامل مع
روسيا
نحن متورطون في حروب دينيه في الشرق
الاوسط علينا ان نتعامل مع صعود الدول
التي تعتبر نفسها قوى مركزيه تاريخيه في
اسيا علينا ان نتعامل مع روسيا لانها تجمع
بين تراجع قوتها الماديه ومحاوله اعاده
تاكيد هيمنتها التاريخيه في مناطق معينه
نحن نواجه تحديا من خلال التكنولوجيا لا
سابقه لها
ثعلب السياسه الامريكيه مثير للجدل حاز
على جائزه نوبل للسلام عام
لكن هناك من يطالب بمحاكمته بسبب جرائم
حرب ارتكبت في كمبوديا ولاوس ودول اخرى
ورغم سنواته المئه الا ان نصائحه وافكاره
الثاقبه ما زالت تلقى اذان صاغيه من كبار
قاده العالم
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات